Together we've increased early childhood education.
Lifted high school graduation rates to new
highs.
Boosted graduates in fields like engineering.
In his last State of the Union address, President
Obama mentioned that graduation rates in our
nation's public high schools are at an all-time
high.
He's absolutely correct.
Eighty-two percent of our public high school
students graduate from our schools.
Here's the challenge.
There's also a rise in the number of students
who enrolled in post-secondary education institutions
with need for remediation in English Language
Arts and Mathematics.
That's troubling.
For one reason, President Obama say we should
increase the number of engineers that we have
in our schools.
Well guess what?
In order to have more engineers, we'd need
to make sure that we have teachers in place
at the high school level, working in his or
her field to train more engineers.
But secondly, we cannot rely on the public
school sector alone to increase the number
of engineers or the number of entrepreneurs
that we need in our nation.
That's going to take private sector choice,
something that I wish the President would
have supported more in his administration.
But with the next administration coming forward,
school choice along with public schools will
make this nation great.
So what are you thoughts about President Obama's
legacy on education?
And check out other AEI scholars' response
to President Obama's State of the Union.